[Music]
hello everybody hey oh hey oh I never
get to [ __ ] do that every time I come
out Jeff just got it shuts it down
welcome to black man beyond where we get
to [ __ ] rock that [ __ ] how we want to
rock that [ __ ] my name is Mark Barnard
there was supposed to be a dude standing
next to me who's not not him he's he's I
love this man
but he is off doing keV [ __ ] which means
for the next two months you get me guys
is so sweet
yeah keV is off on the on the reboot
Roadshow I think he just did Jersey and
I think he's off to [ __ ] I don't know
Chicago Detroit
so I some other place
Central America he's he's on he's on the
road to Katmandu I think so yeah Malcolm
Barrett is supposed to be my co-host
Malcolm Barrett is an actor and not that
actors are bad actors are lovely people
but sometimes they get jobs and like
have to like go do [ __ ] and like I get
the [ __ ] phone call at literally like
7:30 is like hey so I'm still on set and
I'm gonna be to like 9:00 and and then
so it'll take me 20 minutes to get there
is that cool I said listen what am I
gonna do you're a [ __ ] actor I'm just
a schmuck behind the bar you come when
you come and we'll be here and we will
we will welcome you with open arms and a
little bit of side I because you left me
out here by myself did anybody get to
see Jay and Silent Bob reboot
did did you see me I ya know my lines
because alright so here's what happened
okay okay what happened was Kev's like
hey when can you come down to New
Orleans and be in the movie and I said I
have a job keV like and like I can only
doctor's appointment but so much to like
fly out of state
on like a Thursday to show up on a
Friday is they weren't shooting on
weekends at all so I gotta be there for
a [ __ ] week day so I'm like all right
man I'll come down no problem because I
wouldn't miss it for the world I gotta
support my brother so I got on a plane I
had a two day doctor's appointment
whatever maybe I have leukemia
maybe not it's unclear it's a lot of
tests for me to clear that and so I out
to New Orleans I get there at like 3
o'clock in the afternoon and and Jordan
his producing partner psych all right so
call time is 6 p.m. and we're it's it's
a night sheet I said okay that's cool no
problem my plane lands at 3 I can check
into my hotel get over to set by 6:00
which I do because I look at clocks and
[ __ ] and and I know how to be on time
because if there's one thing a black
person can't be is like not on time and
then it's a whole [ __ ] thing so like
let's just cut I'm gonna be there 6
o'clock on the dot
so I get there and like ok we're
shooting inside this this giant [ __ ]
ballroom it's supposed to be the
chronicon said it's the finale of the
movie where Kevin is playing Kevin Smith
and in this scene it's not he's not
silent bobby's Kevin Smith and he's
introducing his [ __ ] panel at
chronicon and we want you to be in the
audience I'm like cool no problem
he's shoot doing a bunch of coverage so
it's gonna be a minute all right
six o'clock passes seven o'clock passes
eight o'clock passes and then I noticed
a couple of dudes kind of sitting in the
crowd also one of them is dressed is Jay
one is Simon Bob and it's uh it's it's
Chris wood and Jesse Rath both of whom
had been on Supergirl and they flew in
from Vancouver literally just like I did
just to do this [ __ ] cameo so we're
all chilling for like you know a couple
of hours
and like dinner break what time's dinner
dinner is it like 11 o'clock at night
alright [ __ ] it that's cool I'll have
you know shitty craft service food and
then like midnight rolls around and then
like 1 o'clock rolls around and then
like 3 o'clock rolls around and we're
all just like sitting here in this like
holding pen for Schmucks waiting for
them to get around to shooting our scene
and meanwhile Chris is like hey I gotta
fly back to Vancouver at 6 a.m.
there's I got it literally get on a
plane because I'm moving out of my
apartment to move in with Supergirl so I
just can't like do this all morning and
so somebody passes the words of Kevin
he's like oh [ __ ] okay can we buy me a
new plane ticket no he's moving in with
Supergirl oh [ __ ] alright so 4:15 comes
and they're set throwing alright we're
ready for you were ready for him like
great I get my costume he puts me in the
[ __ ] James he puts me in a fat man
I'm Batman hockey jersey it's just too
small but whatever and and a [ __ ]
baseball hat oh my god
to do this scene and they march us all
down there it's me and the [ __ ] you
know where the Cameo dudes well flew in
from out of state to come and do this
thing and so Chris and Jessi I kinda we
could put some mics on everybody and
Chris and Jessi go in there and get mics
and they don't have one from me and I'm
like but keV I spent like nine hours
inventing in a lab rebecc-- story for
this character you know like I I've
internal life for this dude who like the
the job is supposed to be that I'm the
snotty [ __ ] movie critic who's
sitting here watching like Bluntman and
chronic reboot who's got all kinds of
salty things to say about it I made some
salty [ __ ] up I got practice I've been
doing this with you for like five years
I know how to slam a shitty movie at
second nature and he's like know what I
want you to do is I want you to be so
disdainful of what you see that you fall
asleep I said
so I'm gonna fly like a thousand miles
and like miss two days of work to
pretend to be asleep on camera at five
o'clock in the morning yeah alright it's
your movie man so like two [ __ ] guys
got mics and they're like what I'm gonna
say I'm gonna be french-canadian and I'm
just gonna be like an [ __ ]
and that'll be cool I'm gonna make funny
[ __ ] I'm gonna say bad [ __ ] about
Melissa even though she's my fiancee but
it's gonna be double funny cuz I'm
making fun of Supergirl and that's cool
okay
can I can I wake up in this scene like
could I at least be prompted by iron Bob
smashing through a window and open my
eyes he's like oh no that's good that's
good said but I have things I could say
not that's that's alright so that's what
we do like it's me kind of pretending to
be asleep for a while and then like
these two guys to talk in and I'm like
alright I'm gonna wake up I'm I look
over at him I would be like wow and then
they're gonna keep talking I'm like and
that iron Bob is gonna come smashing
through the wall I'm gonna be like oh
all of that [ __ ] got cut out so it's
literally just me like just staring down
the back lessons like and so I see the
movie for the first time at Kim's house
was like did you see yourself I'm like
yeah no I did i I I'm very happy that I
made it in the cut given how crucial I
am to the movie is that I wasn't ever
gonna cut you out I was looking you sure
though okay so like you cut me out
before I showed up but
nah man it's awesome and then I go to
the premiere and like it's one thing I
ever wanted to do this for losers
nevermind like my life's goal you guys
is to be on camera all I've ever wanted
is to be on the big screen never wanted
that ever so to go to this movies and
like see my fat ass on that screen well
I just crammed like a spam can into this
hockey jersey with a backwards baseball
cap and like I didn't get a chance to
got my hair cut so I got a tough so
white coming on the side I'm like nah
keV I saw all of it is again and in the
credits it's like sleepy podcaster but
Mark Bernardo I was like you know what
man thank you
honestly like I would not have missed
for the world being part of this journey
but like I could have said some [ __ ] on
the way is it not perfect see right like
the inner depths and the contours of
that dude like all of the life that he'd
seen all of the the Agony's and
ecstasy's and the tragedies of like man
alive what if what if I go in what if we
get Cavs permission and I'm one of your
next solo shows I'll cut all of your
your tanks together and we can show a
highlight reel that's all the people in
the room that would be great and then I
could do like the commentary track for
like years where he remembers that
shitty decisions he made in 1998 here's
when the gonorrhea is flaring up like
all of that stuff so ya know that would
be amazing
thank you because I will feel redeemed I
will feel as if I did a thing once I
left it all on the field you know like
there's nothing left in the tank
it's a no I'm not I'm an actor now so
I'm feeling the anguish of having given
my all everything I had to this role
that the director didn't think was
important
so that's that's fine I'm not bitter I'm
thrilled to have been a small part in
Jay and Silent Bob reboot but that's not
what we're gonna talk about today except
that I just did for a while and I know
it's weird but it's my show tonight you
guys you know what I wanted you know is
it anybody's birthday today is her
birthday I think we should all sing
happy birthday because again it's my
show and as far as anybody on camera
knows it's also my bar so this is coming
ability belongs to me tonight and we're
singing happy birthday all right one two
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you
happy birthday dear
happy birthday
[ __ ] yeah could have done that in your
movie keV okay so I have a I have a
friend in the house who's not Malcolm
but she's way more awesome than Malcolm
because a she's she be she showed up on
[ __ ] time my friend
Jacqueline Kohli who was a senior editor
senior editor for [ __ ] Rotten
Tomatoes she it's my show tonight
she she's written a book called I wrote
a book well that's her Twitter handle
it's like Jackie Coley I wrote a book
but she and I are going to talk about
Star Wars for a little bit because
trailer dropped today yesterday
space horses I don't know how time works
anymore but as far as I know was brand
new
so hey give it up for Jackie Kelly ha
oh [ __ ] you have notes Oh like so wait a
minute cuz I have another side of this
story cuz Jacqueline was at work at her
office today and I get a Twitter DM from
this one saying hey Malcolm things
happenin let me know if you can co-host
with Watchmen and star wars need to know
like right now I'm like you're really
assuming that I am always on Twitter and
I was so I was able to be like yeah like
so let me look at Watchmen again from a
more critical eye let me look at Star
Wars again from our critical eye
normally it's like ingrained but I'm
busy
I'm gonna Ward's editor and so like I
had to like write some stuff down but I
got some notes oh look I gotta make sure
I'm not embarrassing you here is the
difference is that I used to be a
journalist and you are a journalist so
I've like abandoned that like i'ma write
some [ __ ] down and do my homework but
I'm glad I'm glad somebody was taking
this seriously today I mean I'm Malcolm
only because none of these people wanted
to see me tonight
I'm gonna at least make it good for
y'all excellent so okay
walk me through your history with Star
Wars like what what does this movie mean
to you this movie means to me a lot I'd
have a shirt on right now got ya
practice lenses Leia cuz I like Soul
wars as we call it yeah Star Wars and me
I think from what my parents told me and
this does date myself I went to one of
the movies when I was baby and I gotta
like think back to I guess finish no no
I think it was Return of the Jedi I was
like and and giving you I'm like helping
out
I got 15 no appreciate you yeah no
that's that was what happened on that
one so I was literally born watching
Star Wars my dad's a huge sci-fi fan
alien aliens Star Wars he sat me down
before the age of eight and was like you
will not be a [ __ ] you're gonna watch
this [ __ ] watch it all day yeah dad
captain Coley wasn't [ __ ] around you
really want that okay
and so this being the the conclusion of
at this point now eleven movies right
how are you feeling how did this may be
controversial how did you feel about
last Jedi I thought last Jedi was like
watching the home run derby because
there was like so many balls that got
hit out of the park and like connected
but there was a equal amount of whiffs
sometimes but I appreciate the swings I
really enjoyed watching the swings and I
overall enjoyed the movie but it was
like watching the homerun Derby and you
know when someone like sorry this is
nerds maybe I don't understand sports
imagine trying to hit something and not
connecting I wasn't making any
assumptions okay no no yeah it's like
trying to cut a cake but like missing
the cake every now and again you just
mix them off the edge like that level of
Dark Souls where it just keeps moving to
the right when you're trying to get that
last kill shot that was what watching
The Return of the Jedi was like so so
then it's safe to say you were excited
at the prospect of being able to put
this to bed yeah in a way that feels
whole yeah complete and meaningful and I
remember when George Lucas after Episode
six and everybody was pissed at him was
like I'm not doing anymore
there was a plan to do three more and I
remember being like legit depressed for
like a good month of like but I just
assumed that we would get to nine
like I just assumed that this was the
thing because we'd always talked about
it so I was just happy that we did it
and people can be mad about it but we
have 9 Star Wars movies and there was a
time where I didn't think that was gonna
happen so yeah I'm completely excited ok
and so how did you feel about the
trailer
this final like I've I loved the first
rise of Skywalker trailer because it did
the thing of oh [ __ ] you're just
tickling every sort of nostalgia zone
that I have at once and like you got
Billy Dee Williams to squeeze into a
cockpit again wide literally squeeze a
little bit shoehorn Billy I'd seen Billy
recently he dropped some pounds they put
him on that he put him on that old on
that Carrie Fisher died on that on that
Mark Hamill diet to him mark also
dropped a few yes like listen we cannot
butter your hips to wedge you with
behind the cockpit of a falcon son you
got to lose some weight but like you got
Lando you got [ __ ] you know general
Leia again you've got lightsaber battles
not on lava but on waves like it it did
the thing of and the music like it's
incorporating a bunch of different
themes like it's the return of the
Empire love theme meets that it's
awesome and then you get the [ __ ]
Emperor laughs at the end my problem
it's not even a problem with this most
recent the final trailer is that they
have nothing new to show us really aside
from I bet you c-3po ain't making it I'm
sorry like the one thing I am sure that
trailer is full of lies so
that's what I feel I enjoyed watching
the trailer it was a little mini
entertaining lie that is not gonna mean
anything for the actual narrative of the
film but I have a theory okay that the
language of the trailers is always
relevant to the movies because you
remember the force awakens you know
Lupita comes on who are you you know and
it was all that kind of stuff wait a
minute and then it returned the Jedi
like Rian Johnson really foretold what
he was gonna do he's like let the past
die kill it if you have to and he sure
as [ __ ] did in that movie uh he also you
know was like this is not gonna go the
way you think and I think millions of
message boards proved him right there is
a lot of that like what ended up
happening in the movie in the language
it was just none of the visuals were
correct and so in this trailer I was
very much listening like this will be
the spark that burns down the first
order like that was true because there
was a spark of the force anyway
I'm listening to everything in this
trailer ignoring all of the visuals
because their lives that's it that's
fair
I did however like feel a tremor in the
force imagining Kevin watching that
trailer and I just crying buckets I just
want one last look at my friends the
videos now when you search Kevin's name
because like whatever I listen but like
I haven't been up I'm busy I'm gonna
Ward's editor so like right now I'm like
sitting like trying to be like what do
you think of cats and videos right now
Kevin Smith or him either crying or
talking about like I'm so glad I didn't
die and that's it that's like it's
entire youtube search history yeah
there's a lot of luck I love that about
him but he's all about that [ __ ] and so
it feels as if JJ put that in just to
make him cry yes honestly they're buds
like it's a day it's not the same
I could totally see that but no it was a
great trailer the internet was very
enamored with the horses like I don't
know why why was everybody did anybody
have issues with the horses anybody here
I mean I just never know why there are
[ __ ] horses I mean there's teddy
bears there is whatever the the ha
things like what was it again Tong Tong
tom-toms there you go like there's
animals all around they made weird fur
horses if there's if there's one thing
we learned from the last Jedi its nobody
wants to watch [ __ ] riding
horses like it was the most boring part
of that movies like what are they doing
camp and knocking over casino how are
they getting away
I don't know [ __ ] space horses why
just cuz hey it worked for the pork so
you never know I don't know I'm gonna
hold out the fur verses are fine and I'm
just still picturing that that Old Town
Road with Finn and the new black girl
and Matt and I'm sorry like that sold me
for that alone you have to have the
horses to get that clip so the horses
are [ __ ] dope I feel like the old
town road is more like Finn and Poe a
little black girl it's like gay people
accepting of somebody like what is it
like gay baiting and it's like Star Wars
fans with storm whatever it is what do
they call it storm storm pilot yeah
storm pilot like so basically the only
time it's acceptable for Star Wars fan
to be like give you more of this gay
[ __ ] and then also like lesbian people
to be like it's okay for you to pretend
you're gay for us it's like they're
shaking hands underneath and like that's
absolutely true
yeah I just I kept on having this
feeling of I know they're manipulating
me because that's the job of a trailer
you still like manipulate you went to
buying tickets early and I did so it
worked
were you seeing it at mature man I am
seeing it in the dome yeah Alamo
Drafthouse cuz I'm from Texas and that's
really nice yeah I bought it I don't
care about press
go see it okay so so yeah it was just it
was a little anticlimactic given that
the way these trailers have worked and
the way these movies are working and the
way JJ likes to work is let me keep
increasing your rent anticipation for a
thing let me show you the undeniable
reason why you have to show up and I
didn't have that new reason other than I
guess horses but I'm not a horse that
you literally danced up there like this
is Star Wars you would've bought a
ticket yeah but like romance me a little
bit you know but Star Wars knows they're
getting lucky at the end of this
transaction you're expecting them to
work is one of the things like she's
come on make you feel special just like
whisper so like put on perfume like put
something some Lou Rawls on in the
background you'll never find you know as
long as you know I'm not gonna keep
going this is this is the ninth one this
relationship is going on for decades
you're really expecting way to much just
say I'm a committed person I'm in it for
the long haul but once every three years
[ __ ] make it special so yeah what
would it what did you guys think did you
dig did you not dig how do you feel how
many people really liked it how many
people thought it was good how many were
like it's good enough how do you go
we're like nah I I'm hearing some nos
over there
whatever again I don't bought a ticket
though Jason tell me tell me how you
feel I think I think watching force
awakens and then watching last Jedi and
then watching this trailer it's like JJ
Abrams was the cool kid in the bully on
the player
hi I'm mr. Star Wars and then Ryan
Johnson came in and like kicked sand in
his face and JJ went home crying Ryan's
like now I am let the past die and now
this trailer is like hey remember let
the past die I hope you didn't cuz we're
bringing it all back baby
remember Star Destroyers we got those
remember Death Star how could you forget
it's in every Star Wars movie we got
that to land oh we got that in that one
shot there's that that Akbar guy that
they killed in the last movie we got a
guy that looks like him his name's not
gonna be Akbar it's gonna be SAC bar but
it's basically him like kylo ren's mask
remember when they smash that that made
me sad we're gonna weld that [ __ ] back
together
it's literally like the Emperor is
raising a star district I'm assuming as
the Emperor out of an ocean just three
like it's still here
yeah just like Yoda it's like remember
when the good guy did that with the next
wing the bad guy can do with an even
bigger ship and he doesn't even lose his
breath yeah I will never forget the fact
that JJ took tiling in the first trailer
it was like 90 seconds long and of those
90 seconds eight of them were spent
welding a [ __ ] mask back together
it's all lies I'm sorry y'all are
getting amped up for this it's always
lies so I will say space horses is Star
Wars is a kind of a space Western right
it's about time that's new space horses
we haven't seen real good space horses
since tauntauns it's not a Western it's
a very elaborate economical and
administrative story about taxation
routes and trade blockades
it is not for kids you guys it is legit
like how to do government now if this
won't be the first time I've been called
a prequel apologist and it won't be the
last but I will say that a story about
quid pro quo between different
governments with a tyrannical guy who's
trying to take over the universe has
certain relevance in the year 2019 I
don't know what you're talking about I
choose to not acknowledge that because
it will depress the [ __ ] out of me how
do you how do you feel are you gonna
strap in for the 27 hours Star Wars
marathon I have a job
sorry no I can't in fact I had to very
carefully plan my Star Wars purchase on
the 19th mmm and to make sure cuz I'm
literally catching a flight the next day
yeah this is I'm gonna be one of those
people that says something I'm doing
cool cuz I'm going to watch Eddie Murphy
on SNL that weekend yeah I don't care
you can judge me that is literally lay
the [ __ ] did I invite you up here just
to make me feel bad about the [ __ ] I
want to do and can't anymore like
anything in this business that you know
how this is it's not a real thing until
you're holding a ticket though so I
could look real stupid in 3 months when
I'm sitting at home watching it I don't
get to go but hey jag was going on shut
up but you know think about me on the
22nd the December y'all pray for me I I
I'm not gonna do it because I've spilled
mud in that blood before of like living
in a movie theater for a day and a half
I did that for the infinity war marathon
which hurt so much
you can't do that over the age of I
think like 35 like no made for like two
children yeah do you know they did that
at the Alamo with a guy during the force
awakens like stayed the whole time like
he had to keep watching the force
awakens' they did like a marathon and it
was sort of like holding your hand on a
car like the last man standing one
motion I think it's either a lifetime or
a year's worth of movie tickets I think
it was lifetime movie tickets yeah
something ridiculous the dude I saw him
on like our like 20 of the force awakens
because he did the entire the entire
series and then that dude was like I
hate this movie he's like I hate Star
Wars that's the advertising of it it was
so bad but he won and it was so funny as
the dude that quit against him literally
turned to him in like our 27 it was like
you will kill yourself to do this won't
you and he was like yeah like he just
was like I see this look in your eye
like you're not gonna let this go so I'm
just gonna go i but at least the Alamo
Draft House has reclining seats but you
can't fall asleep if you fell asleep
it's the end of the contest oshi yeah
like he has to stay awake yeah oh I
should have mentioned that part that's
why he hated the movie and everybody in
it oh yeah he hated the movie and
everyone in it because he was looking
around and he was just like I can't
sleep I can't really drink because then
you'll fall asleep as well that is some
jigsaw saw [ __ ] anyway they had monitors
watching them they would sit down like
contestant monitor contestant monitor
for like some it's on the internet
google it I don't know yeah it was it
was incredible [ __ ] that yeah no I did I
did 31 hours 32 hours in the El Capitan
which those [ __ ] seats have if you've
never been people at home don't ever go
because like if you can live in any
other movie theater that has like real
cushions and like
and maybe they'll bring you a drink or
something you can like nod off and
comfort the [ __ ] L cap is like a
theater from 1922 that was built to
destroy minds and bodies no there's
still it's like being on an airplane
that has been shrunk and so you're just
like yes and your butt hurts and then
they don't recline at all they're diner
maidens of movie theater seats and and
so I did was that it was the Marvel
movie marathon before infinity war and
it wasn't even every movie was only
sixteen of at that point the twenty
movies they know right they lied in the
advertisement they that's not they it
was it was the first appearances of
everybody like the important sequels
that you had to have [ __ ] Civil War
in there because you have to do
spider-man you had to have Ultron
unfortunately I wrote two thousand words
about how that's the linchpin of the MCU
and maybe that's what made Josh Wheaton
go crazy because they made him set up
all this other [ __ ] so yeah but it's
not good but it has some cool points but
it's like why why but yeah and it was I
mean it was of the events I've been to
that almost killed me
that was probably the most fun but it
almost killed me and the theater smelled
like chick-fil-a ass because chick-fil-a
was the food sponsor so every meal six
meals were brought to you by chick-fil-a
some people left though and like came
back you really one of the few that like
I drew I decided I would walk out when
there were it breaks between them and
like breathe real air and like maybe get
some Sun and then go back in and take my
punishment like a man but there were
some people like I got a hotel room I
took a shower
oh you this somebody here did it yeah
like I've seen these movies I know I've
seen them too this is the point pain is
the point I can't do it but there's
always a part of me that's like I mean
would you do it for like charity cuz I
can see you like raising a lot of money
if you did it something like that [ __ ]
Jackie now I have to do I'd have done it
for like real money but now I got to
give it away because you do I mean I
know you're a good person like Mark and
I know each other but well he's the type
of guy that literally will give anything
that he can for other people so I know
you would do that but you would and
we're all gonna guilt him throughout
this show listen I can do it I'm just
kidding how did you die well for charity
what did you do maybe that's why because
I'm not getting Evan otherwise unless I
donate a bunch of money to I don't know
[ __ ] kids sick ones
you're not sick ones just [ __ ] kids
make a wish for somebody ones are sick
see that's why I'm not getting to heaven
because I say [ __ ] like that alright we
we should talk about the thing that was
on the air over the weekend in case you
nobody else saw it it was a cowboy's
Philadelphia Eagles game did you guys
watch that game what sports no did you
not watch me well the weekend thus the
notes people because that is a challenge
Theriot are now on okay I'm going to
name drop a little bit only because it's
part of the story
I interviewed Damon Lindelof for The
Hollywood Reporter once like six years
ago and spent like three days with a
dude and I can photo shoot I got fancy
ass goddamn clothes
because writers never dresses fancy as
you do if you're in a photo shoot is I
can I keep that and we said no grace
you're a writer
dude like Brad Pitt can walk away with
that [ __ ] you can you know where you are
but uh so interview defer for a while
and we kind of hit it off because he's a
nerd and I'm a nerd and then we kept in
touch over over the years and I just
started working on Castle Rock and and
we had had our like annual hey we should
have lunch and we never did but that
time he's like you know let's [ __ ]
out lunch so I'll go to lunch with Damon
and you know it's like an hour of just
kind of like hey man you see this movie
because we're nerds and then at the end
of it it's like hey so Warner Brothers
came to me with a thing that I don't
know if I should do and I said ooh this
is interesting it's like what is it he
says well they asked me if I wanted to
do Watchmen as a TV show and I said why
and he said precisely he's like I don't
think it should ever be anything but the
book he like the book is one of my
favorite books in the world I love it to
death
there is no reason on earth to try and
adapt that book because a the book is
perfect and B they did it once it was
bad so is like I don't know if I should
do it or not and and the one bit of
advice that I have for him was
somebody's gonna do it so at the very
least because you loved it you know well
the land mines are and maybe you can
find a way to tell a story that is not a
rehash of what we already had but does
something new in this world it did a lot
new he did a lot and so like I mean he
went off and I literally haven't seen
him since every now and again I'll
[ __ ] email him and then you know
[ __ ] first trailer started drop was
like oh damn that's for reals oh [ __ ]
that's really happening in Regina King
oh that's cool
and then I saw it and I was not at all
prepared for what Watchmen was gonna be
I was a little prepared have you guys
all seen it before we go too deep
[Applause]
I mean we're not gonna spoil heavily but
we're gonna like you got to talk about
some [ __ ] yeah so yeah if you haven't at
home haven't seen it yet you're in for a
treat
yeah five four three two one
now we're gonna spoil the [ __ ] out of it
and you're warned and you can go off and
watch great british baking show which if
you haven't seen you guys have seen
great british baking show right have you
not though dude it's [ __ ] amazing
yeah and they're nice it's a reality TV
show we're like nobody's like they're so
nice it's a reality show when nobody
wins any money yeah
like literally these are the nicest
British people with the worst teeth if
you've ever wanted to see like the the
galleries our teeth can be [ __ ] up
like watch Great Britain's baking show
because there's always some dude was
like 70 years old who's like he's got
that one tooth is like seceding from his
mouth it's like I'm making a break for
it
but it's literally like the nicest
people who just get attempt in the
middle of the woods over a weekend like
which is gonna bake what are we gonna
make in a tent in the woods and it's
always raining because it's the UK and
it's the most diverse reality show
you've ever seen Biggers is always like
some lady in a hijab and some duties
like a Sikh and then here's this like
old Indian lady in tears I mean none of
them are attractive not to be seen but
they're not like survivor attractive
where does like the so I'm like 24 years
old and I was a Playboy model but now I
want to win a million dollars so let me
stop myself and push things for a month
this is just like I'd like to bake
breads
[Applause]
the other way or over so or you could do
that hi a little bit but you should come
and do the thing with us this is my show
you want to come be part of the show
sweet I know you come see in the middle
this is literally happening on it's
awesome
where's your camera good to celebrate
that man be fat man be on and black man
be off the fattest blackest person I
know black Santa yeah excellent black
Santa all right we got a camera up there
they should have been one over there but
not anymore
yeah yes yeah over here yeah yeah so
yeah [ __ ] weird man
we it's [ __ ] theater-in-the-round
right now excellent I mean we were just
talking about great british baking show
which is the goods we talked about it on
sunday we did we have a blurred group i
don't know is this a secret it's your
group dude alright put this [ __ ] on
twitter it's not a one day yeah now we
have a we have a blurred group it's a
bunch of black nerds for those who don't
know we go alright thank you
give it up for black people being smart
solid niche
[Laughter]
nobody they were playing by ear yeah and
so what we talked about we could have
talked about the Great British Bake Off
yeah baking [ __ ] yeah we talked about
that we're talking about The Watchmen
now yeah we started watching yes and
then before we got into spoilers we took
a detour look he's got a like you got to
undress for The Watchmen series yeah you
got a flexibility hey wait a minute
[ __ ] listen wait a minute though
reparations right there I want to talk
about because that was the watchman the
watchman was so like a role mad for
Asians yeah what they did it seemed as
though they almost substituted this is
alternate reality right like it seemed
that though they substituted Reagan for
Robert Redford
yeah actually and became the sort of if
you see who's seen the Watchmen seems
like the right group for that question
yeah I also warned people if they hadn't
seen it we're gonna do spoilers a bit
like not beat spoilers but we're gonna
glance off couldn't even care not my
show ones television of the nurse I'm
not show 45 minutes late I was shooting
I was I was doing it I was shooting a
thing which is why I'm late
not like a general a student I'm a
supercool actor so I was a shoot the
thing that I can't talk about because of
course cuz actors can everytime you can
never tell you it's like the first thing
I've never been able to talk about it'll
come in April everything else is like
can we guess yeah yeah what do you what
do you think the thing is that I just
came from the movie that you were
shooting that you can't talk about I'm
looking at his face cuz like am i trying
to see what they would have quit what it
was like Hollywood would hire me no
because you
on some weird goatee I'd be like all
right it's doing a period piece but this
is now I'm guessing this is now okay
that's all I got really good I'm not
gonna lie to you you freakin nailed it
happens during 2019 what you what's your
what you get one guess I'm trying to I'm
trying to fit you can't talk about it
can't talk about it's not it's not a
major Marvel movie or something all
right okay I am shang-chi [ __ ] that
other dude I'm black leopard Oh like
we're actually it's not because you're
filming in town there's like a list this
Robin thing right so Watchmen yeah watch
me yeah we won't talk about the young
Nick Fury movie yeah it's cool rich fury
Rick Nick angry I'm doing a shelf Oh
Nick Nick perturbed on Disney Plus gonna
be Nick perturbed on the booze I'm sick
of you mother [ __ ] it's a mess one
that grow on its yeah it's a solid show
this is what you do for like the whole
half-hour our senior [ __ ] bit with
this thing of this show
what's this stick of this show you
always have to figure out this stick of
the show when you join and you guessed
who you guys talk about comics
ironically almost which pisses people
off it's got to be annoying so who watch
the Watchmen I'm watching the Watchmen
[Applause]
my favorite thing was talking about like
I know Malcolm and I gonna talk about
Watchmen oh by the way we're talking
about race because this is maybe the
blackest show that's on TV show on earth
this is like when Dan Fogelman -
watching the black show which is this is
us like y'all didn't know that yeah yeah
HBO is tricked out and watching the
blackest show on the show is telling you
got arrested by the cops yesterday I was
on its way to HBO show the show it's ID
it was like hello I'm the watchman yeah
you live in this neighborhood yeah yeah
oh it's Tyler Perry opening weekend so
ya know we knew another how black black
it makes macaroni and cheese out of the
government cheese okay we need to really
stop watch me I'm so black The Watchmen
is so black Liam Neeson is looking for
nobody's stopping that so the watchman
is so black it was late for its own time
slop fire these jokes are fine these are
fire jokes
pictured right now is Kevin watching
this show who've been like but like
leave for seconds
[Applause]
you never should've let him do NBA
all-star weekend in Houston Texas there
you go
this show is so black Wes Anderson won't
put it in the movie symmetry jokes so
watch men watch is a solid program yeah
starts off that way like that Oh watch
me so black the first movie to premiere
on UPN that's that's the line
upn a lot of offended UPN Watchers here
I'd I'd like that Desmond fight for
program leave it alone I used to love
the homeboys in outer space
this is [ __ ] malarkey a lot of it
sick of this [ __ ] people maligning
Desmond poo flavor
so this parks people are pissed off this
parks isn't getting its due
oh no one's an early Terrence Howard fan
no guys guys guys next time baby
you can't hit them all so I'm the only
one watching sparks on UPN so you don't
think so [ __ ] sensitive woody [ __ ]
clowns you've been late you guys
watching sparks so race riots yes so
anyway Watchmen starts off very much
like this Watchmen I love watching to
watch Watchmen starts off so here's
what's interesting about the Watchmen
right it starts off with the Tulsa
Oklahoma with some we call riots the
massacre which is a real thing that
happened in American history black Wall
Street yeah closer than this they yell
at me during this black massacre story
all right it's a choice where you try to
help me I get it
so it's crazy it's it opens on these
bombings and the shootings of this
prosperous black town and a lot of folks
thought it was like an alternate history
thing that was happening in an alternate
reality but it was actually based on
something that happens that's not taught
about a lot in our history books which
is the bombing the assault on black Wall
Street which was black guy gets accused
of assaulting white guy whole bunch of
white people then try and lynch him they
get deputized and they'd go and
slaughter the whole [ __ ] town private
planes bomb it bajo bothers call that
it's a departure from the comic books
because it's unclear if Alan Moore the
mage of Southampton
yeah has like ever met a black person I
don't know I don't know but also he
doesn't like any version of the Watchmen
he's ever seen he doesn't like any
version of anything ever been made based
on his work yeah would you say only the
artists name is on the show he's the
only one ever cashes the check who is
that guy that is Nate Gonzalez he's part
of the family
okay yeah sort of cool shirt yes it's
got a lot of information so we'll allow
him to chime in on that three 300 killed
in one afternoon and a day and that was
they say it was probably one of the
reasons why black wolf never prospered
in the early 20s because most of the
rich black folks were living in Tulsa so
there's a it's named the most prosperous
term at the time but it's also hugely
coverup and nobody talks about it and I
think the what is it the aid what is it
not National Guard they didn't want to
give a official estimate so anyway it's
the blackest show ever it's a huge
departure and it's a big deal it's a big
deal because it's you know it's
interesting as people talk about the
importance of comic books and who has a
say in what story is being told and and
so this is a story that like a whole
bunch of people are finding out because
of this show which is just preposterous
and amazing and opportune and sad and
and all these myriad feelings and we
happen to know a guy involved in a show
I feel like we can't say his name or
something he's weird about it Dan
yes yeah it shouldn't say his name okay
speaking of people involve the show did
you guys catch the weird cameo from from
like a little show maybe called Sleepy
Hollow
yes what is that missing plays the
creepy Butler too
I did odd man about Quinn yeah Oh is he
oh yeah that's that's a Chabad from
Sleepy Hollow Thomas yeah that's how him
I had to look it up but I was right I
was just a weird coincidence since I
look cuz he didn't have the beard and he
doesn't have the long hair I recognize
that British white like affectation he's
he's amazing I am actually another clue
what I'm working I'm working with
someone from Sleepy Hollow tonight the
horse and the horse it's a space horse
the thing about watch men is the the
comic book is very much about a question
right and the question is you know who
watches the Watchmen there's no actual
super group named The Watchmen there's
no Motown ban in the Watchmen it is just
the idea of who is policing the people
who police us who is keeping track of
those more powerful than we are this
show also is about a fundamental
question which is who gets to be safe
right like is it the police the police
in this world don't get to be safe
because I wear masks because they're
afraid for their own livelihood the one
cop who doesn't wear a mask is down on
[ __ ] Johnson who uh if I was down
Johnson I never wore a man let's just
say it didn't end well for him it didn't
end without wearing a mask but it's like
so much of the way that pilot works is
again we're gonna spoil the [ __ ] out of
this Don Johnson is one cop who
everybody knows who he is
because he feels like he's safe he feels
like he's the avatar of control and a
police and a power in this town and so
when at the end of this thing he's like
you got a call you gotta go the the dude
who got shot is out of the is out of the
ER you can go see him his wife is like
hey you should maybe take some police
escort you should have somebody drive
you he's like no I got this I'm the
chief of police he drives out gets
killed because he thinks he's safe yeah
meanwhile the show has taught us that
the most powerful character in the show
is sister Knight played by Regina Kane
yeah who is ask me like and she's
nothing but agency she's nothing but
power she [ __ ] goes into her secret
cave she puts on her [ __ ] outfit and
she's a
[ __ ] in the face but she is
deathly afraid of where she lives of how
she lives when something goes wrong
she's got the Go Bag with a shotgun up
in the bed I mean if you were going home
to Yaya I would make sure [ __ ] was safe
- cuz girls got it all right I mean
there was some other scenes ladies
ladies yes they're lucky yes I first
discovered him in the get-down he was
freaking amazing yes well that character
doesn't feel safe in their own home in
her own town then what does that say
about who gets to be safe you know what
does that say about who gets to have
control over their own bodies and who
gets to say who has agency over how they
spend their time in their power and
their their very livelihood in
themselves and if Louis Gossett jr. as I
kind of think he is like you meet him
and the very beginning of the show as a
little boy part of the Tulsa
you know Massacre who survives his
father Chuck's a little slip of paper in
his pocket that says watch over this boy
and then we encounter him 105 years
later and he's hoisted Don Johnson up
into a [ __ ] tree and like is that dude
the leader of the white supremacist
group again if he is which I kind of
think he is what does that say about who
gets to control power like who gets to
control fear and who gets a levee fear
as a weapon against everybody else that
was extremely cogent one thing I do I
mean he's obviously gonna show it more
of it I was just like I mean doing lines
in the bathroom at like the family
dinner I was like this dude's got some
layers that weird you know the thing I
kind of actually keyed in on was just
Regina's character because normally that
same archetype of the does a good job a
kind of rogue doing what she wants type
character that's always played by dude
it's always played by dude and normally
at the end of the episode that's the
character like Regina King that's
getting killed to give that dude
motivation for like the rest of the
season and like yaaaa who didn't have
that many lines but he looked good
that's like the wife that's quiet like
they just totally changed that and I'm
like and that episode was directed by a
woman like before the episode
I was like this has too much black in it
to not have black people in that writers
room and this has too much women in it
not to have a woman's eye on it and I
just loved it I live he was definitely
the supportive spouse he was definitely
the attractive supportive actor with a
lot of credits spouse which is which is
what you usually get from the lady where
you're like okay she's been why she's
been acting for years and what okay she
plays lady over there but any a Judy
Greer is always like lady next to people
acting it's always a way
powerful I think it really does a lot I
mean if y'all don't know y'all is about
to blow up he just got cast the matrix
he was an aqua man got candy man next
year that's produced by Jordan fields
company like that guys about to blow me
out yeah what is it
Black Mirror nightmare you know and the
pilot was directed with such careful
craft like there's all of these overhead
shots of [ __ ] that it's just other book
when when Regina King is separating eggs
and like the eggs are in the [ __ ]
smile of the smiley face and there's a
red splotch of blood in the one [ __ ]
yolk
there's that overhead shot of when the
family's at the dinner table and it is
absolutely the Doomsday Clock looking
down on it and Don Johnson is that V
like 11:55 of the Doomsday Clock like
all of this [ __ ] is like none of that's
by accident that is by an artist that's
not working
yeah I also love that there's a set up
where it seems as though you're in an
alternate reality because the racial
paradigms are shifted in a way that
you're not used to one it opens with the
Tulsa massacre which a lot of Americans
are unfamiliar with but then it has the
the white guy driving listening to music
he gets stopped by an officer by a black
officer and it's like very intimidating
and like I know enough black folks who
have been in that situations and have
seen in cinema where that and it sort of
reverses and because of that I I know I
have friends I've seen where people were
like is this the alternate reality is
that and it opens with Oklahoma with an
all-black cast black people like black
people in Oklahoma
is a sci-fi movie this is a comic book
sci-fi thing something's happening and
it was just they were just the cast of
that particular production and her kids
her kids are white she has adopted kids
it it does a really good job of shifting
paradigms and making you think about the
archetypes and stereotypes stereotypes
and ideas of what you have about culture
right off the bat and sort of flipping
it even though it is essentially our
world which is slight differences and
it's it's really amazing to watch that
picture get painted I really like that
and as a fan of I read I read the comic
I read the movie and I think you know
it's in the world of the Watchmen but
not a story that you've seen from the
Watchmen yeah which makes sense to me I
think way more interesting because you
don't have to worry about you know
trying to translate 1970s themes do
thousands really hard yeah and The
Watchmen gave you exactly that like the
movie is shot for shot framed for frame
the comic book like it is every frame
that is in the comic book is in the
movie it's from beginning to end it's
which like literally the only thing they
change is the very end for the movie and
I was a huge fan of movie I [ __ ] love
Watchmen I thought it was great that guy
I'm a guy I was there I [ __ ] think
it's great I don't care I think it's
great I think it does action really well
it's very stylized the colors are
interesting the story is fun I hadn't
seen characters like that or in that
level like I think probably unbreakable
is probably the first where we saw the
sort of bigger superhero characters and
characteristics being brought to a
really greedy reality I think in a way
before the sort of Batman gritty ones
where you saw big yellow capes right
we've got the big garish colors oven
breakable and I'm trying to bring and so
when I saw the watch Watchmen I felt
very much that same feeling because no
one has superpowers right it's just
extremely style of it and so I really I
really like that I mean you were
wondering what the game of the podcast
is the game of the podcast is the Deuter
stands to my right love [ __ ]
a lot and then I stand here and [ __ ] on
it so you're gonna have to stick of the
thing let's do the thing we feel any
other sticking thing I mean I which is
the name of my podcast the stick of the
thing stupid
brought to you by stick bus chicken
thing by hasbro yeah i love the book the
movie is a translation of the book but
not an adaptation of the book and it
feels as if yes the mediums require a
certain amount of flexibility when
dealing and they cut stuff because you
can't just shoot that book like all the
black freighter stuff is gone yeah the
transdimensional squid that appears of
the video this becomes a [ __ ] bomb
that blows up in New York but it's it
was slavish in a way that wasn't deep to
me like he was very surface II it looked
amazing but it never found what felt
like the soul of what that book was
because it had to cut out half of that
book and some of the soul resides in the
black freighter stuff some of that soul
resides in the internal monologues of
these characters that it's hard to do in
a movie did you see that well not that I
sat through it but there was a
director's cut that I heard for the fans
like you that had that opinion they
found it to be more enjoyable did you
watch it I found it more in that it's
like they animated all the black
freighter stuff and they reinsert it
yeah like and that stuff is pretty cool
but it just becomes a longer exercise in
not finding out what it's actually about
you ever see psycho the remake the Gus
Van Zandt yeah yeah we're like Vince
Vaughn is masturbating in the closet
yeah yeah it was like let's do it
exactly the same but the guy from
swingers movie is a perfect example of
what happens when you cast hot actors
when hot actors are hot and then you
don't worry about making the you know
the rest because both of those two were
literally like the hottest thing at that
point I've done another example of that
even though I liked this movie
passengers is another example of that
passengers Brad and Jennifer is not a
good idea that movie was to watch at the
same time yes you know what they should
also it should have been a surprise that
like he you know what I mean yeah
there's a character he's like a great
chance for a better story there's a
great video by nerdwriter where he
breaks down if they would have changed
the order how that was great but we're
talking about the watch sorry Chris
Pratt's a horrible person in that I'm
sorry man but they got a lonely
they got a tree because I look I'm
attractive man I mean I had to let you
out yeah what's guardians
that's my impression of Chris Pratt in
passenger
watch guardian City Jurassic world yo
did you see
hey watch guardians of galaxy dinosaurs
I like what you're a Siqueiros girl
looks good on ironic oh yeah judge me
don't care no I do all of them I'd be in
all of them if anyone asked me but for
now
all right now what it is the music hits
they open the park and I am back to
being like three and half I said it's
it's actually true because I was I
talked about a [ __ ] but I was watching
it last night what does it fall in
Kingdom Kingdom of the dinosaurs and
it's it's one of those things where like
as a dissenting person I'm saying I
don't like this [ __ ] [ __ ] they
let off these goddamn dinosaurs again
are they gonna get out you see some
scene where it's just like the most
beautiful thing like Chris Pratt and and
Ron Howard's kid right school children
named after the places in which they
were conceived yeah yeah yeah yeah Bryce
Dallas Bryce Canyon I'm not gonna do
this yeah no it's nothing to say use I
got another kid you all going somewhere
this is my daughter happy days how young
is this crap all right a lot of Andy
Griffith riffs we want to do that all
right
are you gonna watch the rest of Watchmen
are you strapped in yo I'm so ready I'm
so ready I'm so excited about who this
is gonna piss off
have you met Twitter angry any of these
people I feel like actually the movie I
think it's been like it's it's still 93
percent certified fresh on this tomato
meter and I add what is it Watchmen for
the first season already and honestly I
think it's one of those ones it's on HBO
people are gonna watch it they made
Barry a hit like that I mean and Barry's
a brilliant show but that's not the type
of show that usually breaks through the
consciousness like I yeah they're gonna
watch it West world is about to come
back it's gonna have a great lead-in I
think I think it was - I think it was
too true for people to be as racist as
they
they were like oh is it a thing that
happened he's gonna say some [ __ ] about
that
and that's trended on Twitter all night
long yeah Tulsa Mass yeah yeah yeah and
black Wall Street yeah you're gonna
watch Jackie you strapped in
I'm strapped in I also I'm just a huge
fan of Regina King I love Jay King is
that goddess she's been one of the best
actresses since she was like 11 years
old on 2:00 to 7:00 and that's the thing
she one of the most versatile and you
know full disclosure I worked with her
it's not really disclosure his name
dropping but but full disclosure so what
she's I think she's one of the most
versatile actors of our day I mean she's
been in 227 she's been in Friday she's
Watchmen she's in Southland she was in
the Will Smith movie with the technology
this day she's all the little boys
voices on the booyah Jerry Maguire why
there is nobody who has had as varied a
career as Regina King and brought in
such powerhouse performances there very
few if you could name who've done that
and then I also want to add she also
like is doing this at like 40 to be like
I'm literally gonna be the baddest [ __ ]
in the room and she is like that is so
cool she's not 40 though she's really
yeah she is 43 I'm not gonna help this
black woman's age just no I'm saying
that was a very carefully manicured age
no I mean she's public about it she said
we should like Damon like woody when he
cast her was like and you're gonna go
work girl and she was like yeah I think
she's older I think that way
like we were doing like with Jessie
smell it oh we were quiet at first and
future is that's my age young
[ __ ] better live we're trying
to be quiet to hide it for wasn't Keyser
söze in that age for a bit oh wow I
don't know she's a beautiful woman and
she's doing lovely work she's perfect
and immortal yeah that's all I have to
say about the great Regina King my queen
yeah Regina King so we are all here on
board with [ __ ] Watchmen if you
haven't seen it go see it then you can
come back and watch because we spoil
decent things in it but Jackie is here
for another reason because Jackie wrote
a [ __ ] book I want like markets
literally like I typed this whole damn
thing which I didn't actually what it is
called rotten movies we love and it's
from the Rotten Tomatoes editorial staff
which I'm a member of yeah it's really
dope guys we went through because one of
the things we found is we talked about
these movies and people will like come
up to me and be like why did you give
stepbrothers a rotten rating and I'm
like I did not give stepbrothers a damn
thing I just write editorial on the site
like I didn't do it
however the critics at the time when
they saw stepbrothers they didn't
understand its brilliance it found a
cult status and then people now love it
and it's beloved and we took this
opportunity to kind of sit down and find
some of these films and we enlisted
people like Leonard Maltin I was like a
really fancy film critic we got him to
talk about Rotten movies he loved and a
bunch of other folks you know like April
Wolfe who is soon to be writing black
Christmas she wrote for the LA Weekly
just a ton of critics just kind of
talking about hey this movie may have a
bad score but we love it so I like X vs
7 yeah and it's in here too this is the
the zeros like zeroes the lowest ratings
remember x vs 7 yeah yeah I thought that
was based on a video game when I first
saw it I was
what I was like yo I gotta get this from
my turbo Genesis ever
y'all be ex ub7 but ya know it's it was
really great and Paul Feig did an
introduction for it which is awesome
very cool where can people buy set book
so you can literally buy it anywhere
right now books are sold on Amazon and
you can also go to our website at
Running Press they were the lovely
publisher that let us put out this crazy
thing and luckily for people in the
house once we do our QA the book is
gonna be one of our fancy as prizes
yeah in addition to you in addition to
each book we'll also have a little gift
card slit in there which I see it out
and I'm holding you got this yeah so you
can go to Star Wars on Rotten Tomatoes
yeah and those are Fandango gift cards
that you can use to buy tickets oh yeah
tell your friends tell your rotten
movies we love ya awesome Jackie thank
you so much for coming with me
[Applause]
hey you know we can do now no I love his
[ __ ] works as as is my won't I found
some news now we're talking about some
news let's do the news that's so much
better than what we usually do is that
big thing yeah now let's go man
thank you you guys be witnesses for a
podcast yeah yeah how many times I told
you in every email and message I'm not
listening here we do like a diddy just
for the listeners like boom we got the
moon Sun scatter the universe in the web
sites everything that I could just super
tight you know what happens most of my
money's in movies now podcasts I'm an
actor well I do well now this is it this
is a brother show why I scour the
internet for news that other people
broke and I copy and paste it and then
we talk about it that's solid man right
it's the part where I act like I know
what you're talking about sweet and
because we haven't done this for a while
you never me and it's been a stretch
there's some stuff that's a stale but
important but not like he broke
yesterday did you know that Kevin Feige
is now running the universe Kevin Feige
is doing great he's doing good
microphones yeah he he is now the lord
and master of everything to do with
Marvel yes he's been
named not only he's the head of whatever
he is that of right now but he's now
been named what creative master of
creative officer hey Marvel and it it
now promises everything it had just been
the studios and the movies but now it's
the publishing and more importantly the
television know here's the thing
what's cool is that I feel like the
worlds are gonna be even more connected
now do you know what I mean because you
have this guy but I feel like he should
give himself a cooler title you know
what I mean like you're that you're the
head of everything of a Marvel Universe
why would you call yourself chief
anything I'd be like I'm ambassador or
two doors on the the Abbott can I mean
chief Abbot day lecto yeah Esperanza
supreme day Wakanda DISA Marius because
supreme Allied commander yeah yeah at
TAO at X Esquire he's never gonna make
it
Kevin Feige has that short career yeah
but uh so he's now overseeing everything
in Marvel including all of their TV [ __ ]
which previously had been overseen by
Jeph Loeb who was the executive that
Marvel hired when they first got into TV
and he's responsible for agents of
shield and agent Carter and the Netflix
sort of quintet of shows I love those
shows um some of which fared a little
bit better than others
Jessica Jones who's a big hit the cage
was a big hit daredevil was a big hit I
feel like here are you gonna am I gonna
[ __ ] on iron fist
yeah no no it was yeah we got time it
was I got anecdote about iron fist that
I feel like I can't tell don't do that
you know so I'm running the iron fist
right feels like a lot because I'm
telling it like it's Brooklyn but I
now I'm not gonna tell this to everybody
anyway I run into all these uh defenders
at comic-con uh-huh now this guy's so
nice though then I have this dude he's
so nice he's very nice
have you ever met him I did once at a
convention yo that dude is mad nice man
I was like taking a picture and I was
with like daredevil and I was with
daredevil homie DMV yeah yeah oh my
cousin Pookie daredevil just just dude
in the projects we caught daredevil he
be jumping off for [ __ ] trying drugs you
shouldn't try she's a crazy dude man
you'll jump off that [ __ ] daredevil you
know how I do
oh boy right step away right there boy
right so what's it what's your jaffa
story no I want to take a picture with
daredevil and an Iron Fist leaned in my
office
[Applause]
how'd that go
I was like you'll just take the picture
you should use your fists hit the
shutter he's a very nice guy and he's
stood in the middle so I couldn't crop
because that's not the first time and
over here Matt is all year where they
get cropped out of photo I used words of
like fans with cropped photos of just
the devil and I am losing after damages
a photo of them I talk mess but he's a
very nice guy is horrible artifice but a
nice man I don't know I haven't seen the
show you made wiser decision with your
time than I did because I watched all of
them yo you know what I watched until I
watched until my man what is his name
tan Liu Liu San Luis Tan your ask module
right there weed I did a panel with him
cuz he was almost Iron Fist he was like
the way the Asian guy who was going to
be iron fist and didn't make it and it
was sad his here I could feel like I
couldn't speak about this objectively I
would like to see there's nothing so
please do well this was the crazy thing
right one like there's a huge and you
can't probably like you know it was a
huge opportunity to have an Asian lead
for Iron Fist you know what I mean and
we like how cool would that poster have
been with those people across there but
also Louis tan is a great actor and so
well trained in martial arts this guy is
a machine and is if you watch into the
Badlands this cat is on into the
Badlands now this this dude
yeah what was that she knows you know
she he is a beautiful man this dude is
using all time you go to his Instagram
he's just doing flips with sticks and
nunchucks and stuff you know my
Instagram is me like not showing you me
smoking weed like it's just that's all
the content is not to show you that I'm
smoking weed just lots of you with like
one hand I got out of the frame somebody
walks to me while I'm doing something
legal just doing martial arts look what
I can do
it's not just smoke weed off smoke break
I've got you know buddy he's like
frickin amazing it's so crazy that they
wouldn't so I actually was binging that
to get to him because he wanted to
playing like the drunken master on there
so I was just like wanted to see him go
but so badly but he's gone into the
Badlands and I think he's got some stuff
working right now
because nobody MORTAL KOMBAT it's
playing lowest and Liu Kang yeah yeah
Louis time I play lowest and like that
dude is badass I saw walking with a
little puppy dog he was the most
adorable thing they like see somebody if
I could kill you guys with like a little
dog because he's a human person he's a
human three-dimensional individual likes
things including kind of dogs
yeah yeah def that dude is bad I can't
believe well that's what frustrated me
watching getting back to topic was that
the fighting was so bad on iron fist it
was like you guys ever watch kungfu the
legend continues with David Carradine
and David Carradine it was like he had
the show back in a 70s I think and he
came back and was the legend continues
they still had him and he be and anybody
know this is another case of a white man
taking an Asian person job because it
was supposed to be was supposed to be
Bruce Lee back in a day and in the wound
up being David Carradine and David
Carradine his kung-fu legend continues
and they use him no stunt double and as
a part do they use in a beginning theme
where it goes like this is David
Carradine he's 187 when the movie and
any and he kicks like this he goes like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh they pay this man he just walking the
earth walking are kicking things that
are like this i if it's three feet tall
I got this I'm kicking about he's kicked
is she not a shrubbery no shrubbery was
left was your topics how's your topic
[ __ ]
so yeah Marvel TV TV yeah it's gonna be
crazy man I'm excited I'm gonna defend
all of them so like Marvel TV was like
very siloed away from the movies like
all of those things were like everybody
was hoping my Hoffman it's [ __ ] Luke
Cage gonna show up in a man game no no
because no no but you always knew no TV
cuz that's just a Hollywood thing like
no TV person was gonna make it into the
movie do you know what I mean I never
felt like they were gonna bring them
into the world ever I felt like because
they barely wanted the movie people in
there like they bring Samuel Jackson for
like a line or something like that we're
at the most they'd mention like the
incident at New York or something like
that there'd be like a newspaper in a
background of like every one of those
shows but I think it was just too large
a world and like they want to mess with
the movie money do you know what I mean
right but if they thought they could
have made that and the Hollywood they go
like oh if they're not a movie star
we're not making him a movie star if
he's on TV you know yeah but I think
that now that it's all under Kevin Feige
like all of that [ __ ] becomes fluid like
now that you having a falcon winter
soldiers show now to having a Wan
Division shown are you having a Loki
show it is now oh wait we can do all of
it at once and it would not surprise me
if you know in one of those shows
[ __ ] Tom Hollands spider-man shows up
because you could do that yo you know
who made ifs yo yeah that same dude made
in humans
he worked twice yo that stuff is garbage
[Applause]
yeah I saw in humans in the movies yo
you shouldn't have but I felt somebody
needed to and I was the one cuz in the
movies there's nobody else there but umm
no man that's not and look
Hey Dude who made in humans feel free to
make fun of my stuff whatever I've done
it's all pretty good I'd like to see you
try yes so check my IMDB right now it's
[ __ ] solid I got what I got one
b-movie and nays on purpose it's
10-point Oh earthquake it's a lot of fun
it's not a good movie but it's fun
some days the effects are as good as in
humans go see tempo no earthquakes yeah
that guy's got two Inhumans and all of
Iron Fist here's a guy who liked iron
fist in here same guy who was in love
with UPN want that cross-section of
people that look really liked iron fist
and hates UPN jokes because it's
offensive a Venn diagram Tom being his
[ __ ] inhuman [ __ ] is going down
mockery is safe did you read the comic
book bone back when it was out never
know they're making a thing now they're
on Netflix is make it a series based on
bone animated series it's a gorgeous
[ __ ] book is that something people
are excited about I don't know anything
about it
okay Amy's excited I believe you
yeah it's her birthday perfect you're
just a big sign of that [ __ ] okay
Oh
what you did what would you like about
sorry to give me a second that's alright
what do you like about bones oh man
isn't gonna work you ain't got no
microphones the you only got five
seconds this is close you're gonna get
to famous right now you do you like
monsters this cute monsters it's
adorable [ __ ] monsters happy birthday
to you and you [ __ ] sick dreams and
interests weirdo visit bones based off
the TV show it is yes it is about these
cute adorable little creatures who
travel in the world investigating crime
scene yeah hey phone bone what's that
that's a dead body oh [ __ ] what happened
to oh let's get you tell us what's up a
deep cut knowing that was fun salads for
us for the blurred group Eugene Byrd
fans I'm gonna play this silence for him
when I see him later cuz he's a friend
of mine and it's gonna be awesome so
thank you for not knowing who he is all
day you hear that yeah that's the people
who don't know who you are did
everything he has a long enough career I
can make fun of them [ __ ] with our
base of crickets will put any crickets
like the sound of tumbleweed yeah yeah
whatever that sound is just Eugene's and
every Eugene is a guy you'll knit you'll
make he's an everything you've ever seen
he's an arrow he's the black guy that
was on Beverly Hills and I know - whoa
no thanks think of the black guy that's
him that's the guy sure that's
Rallis the [ __ ] episode the nets what
was Vivek a fox on it no I don't think
that was Beverly Hills 902 now whatever
[ __ ] this is a black guy playing
basketball whatever the [ __ ] show it is
there's Melrose Place speaking of black
people finally Jada pinkett-smith is
black
according to reports and is coming back
to the matrix yo I heard about this yes
Niobe is returning to the Nebuchadnezzar
or whatever the [ __ ] those words mean I
used to have a rat with Nebuchadnezzar
in it how did you do that
lin-manuel Miranda yeah never the better
nevertheless I meet the captain Ned that
never could never [ __ ] I just robbed a
five-syllable word she's yeah you did it
though I did it I don't know when but
yeah I'm excited about that
I played the matrix video game that she
was in do you guys remember that name
was like new [ __ ] when it came out man
like you were doing all types of moves
of stuff like this before Max Payne and
stuff and you I liked combinations and
then the story happened who's the first
one thing would have the cut screams to
the story with the real actors who shot
bonus footage my Denzel finger
they shot bonus footage for the game and
then it was like a kiss [ __ ] Niobe
kissed what's that French lady Oh Monica
Bellucci yes solid video game
just a touch this is a good video game
man we got ladies go to second base what
other ladies yeah no it's great I love I
love transition segue what I love about
Jada Pinkett is acting in her career
Jada Pinkett has such an interesting
career cuz I feel like she just showed
when you're married to Will Smith you
just show up to whatever movie you feel
like I feel like half the movie she
didn't even audition she just walked up
she was like I'm shooting today I mean
give her a cape or somebody I know
next but sure we can find its animated
but yeah yeah be on set for the awesome
you guys see her in Gotham same thing
she walked on the set they were like we
don't have a character for you I'm fish
Mooney that's not is that him fish fish
Mooney I mean I don't know who that is
Gladys I know fish Mooney I don't just
give her the [ __ ] thing we have
penguin waiting he's in I don't give a
[ __ ] she said she's playing fish Mooney
get a [ __ ] you guys we don't let her
do this she's doing it she's doing the
lines now I didn't we didn't write any
you know just go act with their little
little batboy act with her she's she's
returning to the matrix universe and to
balance out her blackness as is Neil
Patrick Harris is also going to be in
the new Matrix movie yeah but to out
balance that whiteness we got Yaya from
get out / see bring a full circle
homeboy from the Tulsa Watchmen BAM but
you know what it's not just about black
this has either been the best idea or
the worst step honestly I don't it's not
my [ __ ] shell you go bounce right
honestly I can blow it up I don't care
man I'll just see Sunday and just be
blowing smoke okay I'm gonna need away
man-eater [ __ ] way man
hey just as much pain either way men
yeah but the The Matrix movies were
always kind of incredibly progressive
when it came to Casting amazingly well I
mean I the watchman of the few years I
on and it was just you know you have
Laurence Fishburne as a sort of guru
like it was amazing I will admit that
I'm pretty sure I was watching it in a
dorm and I slept through it like the
first two times I saw the matrix
I was like our man lots of stuff
happening in there a lot of things going
down is it made by the same guy who did
what's the movie [ __ ] he made a movie
before that words like the same
aesthetic design where it's like switch
it's like Jenica shown bound what bound
yes is that the same people cuz I
remember was a chance to I remember
watching a matrix thing and man they
were in the same jackets from bound
bound was their audition finish for the
mates all I am they written the matrix
and they sold it to Warner Brothers like
we want to direct it they're like you've
never made a movie before and they were
like but we want to do this and they
said we don't know if you can you should
make another movie before we let you do
the matrix and so then they wrote and
directed bound to show them that they
could make a movie and then they were
like okay clearly y'all about leather
[ __ ] but they'll get they good with
leather I guess give them like they got
sure we pants to show up like Joey pants
so if they longer they use Joey pants
and leather than give them the money
every time and when we don't make money
they don't have Joey pants and or
leather now Cloud Atlas has neither
yeah many made bad movies if I offer you
nothing else but this complex critique
some people make bad [ __ ] sometimes
that's how that goes stuff for me check
my [ __ ] discography is perfect
earthquake [ __ ] don't work you know
if that's just a song on the whole
career but you know I'm one of you
that's like the beauty mark on Cindy
Crawford yeah that's what makes it oh
yeah yeah 10-point North quick that's
what makes your human smoothies gonna
make seven more dollars today see you
didn't think you were gonna get anything
out today oh you got two streams I just
see him at home just constantly
refreshing earthquake two streams you
transition [ __ ] on trauma abyss
to hop on the Segway and it's hard
speaking of black people and things zoe
kravitz good right um I'm excited but I
actually think that's a really good
choice i I feel like zoe kravitz has
been putting her work in being there I'm
interested in her being weird mmm I mean
I'm interested she's she's sexy I feel
like she has it like we've seen her but
we haven't seen her do anything that
made you go like like what's the thing
that's pulling us all in here and I feel
like that could be a really fun breakout
role for her
it's always funny watching backlash of
this stuff where someone's like but I
feel like it's only coming from races so
I just try not to watch racist things
like racists are funny because they
don't know history like
this is just weird like he's just what
did you wake up seven minutes ago like
it's just weird and like a weird sort of
racist but it's weak cuz they like mad
at like their like their race swapping
Selina Kyle is just like you've never
heard of Halle Berry or Eartha Kitt this
is a brand-new this is a new thing for
you this is the first time you've ever
heard you just watched I don't know what
version yeah who is that yeah what
version what bubble did you live where
you just watch the second Batman you
only watch that one Batman whose fancy
[ __ ] better not change this
[ __ ] I'm in love I know everything about
Catwoman based off Batman - I can if
they changed his [ __ ] [ __ ]
ethnicity based off this movie I saw it
at one time I'm gonna plant [ __ ]
Bernie woo there's any black people on
Watchmen - I'm with squirrels screw
everything I did not talk about anything
on anything no I'm down for this choice
because I think you're right she could
be a little freaky if she wants to be
and letting her out of that particular
box what the end of the day she is Lisa
Benes kid lenny Kravitz's yeah and then
she's hanging out Jason Momoa as house
or something at least like for holidays
yeah she's at least what are they sure
I'm buddy here cuz I have facts
anybody can have facts okay fax this one
over here with the book and knowing
things information yeah yeah all right
knowledge had to rub off do you know
what I mean you can't be in that house
and not want to put on some leather and
say perfect it is not the first time
brunch
they do that brunch this is to say I
believe she could do it the same way I
knew that Joaquin could be no Joker
because I was like oh this is [ __ ] he
does on Saturdays like they were like
look like really Todd was just shooting
the home movies with him I like walking
is just home dancing I don't know we'll
call it the Joker I don't [ __ ] lose
all right some chittering hey will right
around it huh
right around it do someone he's still
dancing I'll segue cheated a joke oh you
did I don't want to talk about that
because I've done it already
oh let's talk about what's the other
[ __ ] we talked about I got allergies
this is not cocaine
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so my allergies are wreaking us having
crazy
speaking of cocaine did you ever watch
Emmet Ana's jug-band Christmas I'm not
gonna do this with you
what is this Who am I not as drug bang
Christmas that sounds like a racial slur
was a Jim Henson production that fur it
was a Christmas special that aired in
like 1976 now about a bunch of poor
otters who literally have no two sticks
to rub together who the again my
daughter's just like the young kid in
the family who just wants to join a jug
band and like he's got the [ __ ] wash
basin that he poked a hole in so that he
could like put his string in and like
have a little band and win who's a
contest and the prize was like a ham or
some [ __ ] I can't grant the end and
they're big competition was the river
bottom nightmare band and they were like
[ __ ] wolves and they were angry and
scary that we're doing like [ __ ] prog
rock and [ __ ] is this part racist °o°
cuz it's all like white trash okay yeah
yeah it's like white trash versus white
trash for like the white trash ham of
the year okay I'll watch this yeah
you sure it's like adorable and the
songs because it's [ __ ] G Manson it's
a muppet universe Bret McKenzie Britt
Britt McKenzie that sounds familiar
Flight of the Conchords brick brick
brick
brett-brett Kinsey Germaine bright a
Conchords hello right
we're gonna rule attendance right
Jemaine yes right here yeah all right
everyone's present
[Applause]
Britt who isin the bet that bit went
well yeah who has an Oscar for having
written a song for the Muppet movie who
does Britt his Oscar yes Britt has an
Oscar [ __ ] the Jim Henson song sorry
I'm behind on Britt's opus yes for
writing man or Muppet in my man Oh am i
Muppet that one is that how I
accidentally mailed the melody Oscar did
I crush them you really did how did
another song is that a different song in
my man
Oh am i no musical theater people with
me now that's something [ __ ] David
Goulet [ __ ] young called me on my Goulet
[ __ ] right now I'm on my cool a [ __ ] so
giant ring brett-brett
kripp is going to write and do the music
for the remake of Emma daughters
jug-band Christmas they're remaking
they're remaking it was there a call for
that I mean there's always a Christmas
okay white trash needs Christmas
specials - they do need now more than
imagine you white trash and black Santa
come down
which is [ __ ] do we light a fire sure
had a hey like Sam you had to do the
same thing when y'all took Jesus so just
take these [ __ ] gifts go about your
day I don't know how he's Joe works but
[Applause]
we'll try man there's just a long career
I had it was good
Sally's a good push I'm sad I didn't get
the breakout but it went it went pretty
well
we should talk just a little bit before
the news is over okay I was a good
segment that was awesome the news is
always good you gotta bring back this
song is gonna be a hot thing don't suck
JC we got to cut that [ __ ] up and drop
it in everything drop that [ __ ] JC drop
that [ __ ] on me we're gonna get to Q&A
in a second but you were in the boys the
TV show
[Applause]
it's a good career take care everybody
it's thrive save tip your waiter ha what
how was it how did it feel to play a
writer who never gets laid you tell me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] come on man
hit it hit it I tried not to tell it
that was that was the [ __ ] dilemma of
the agency I don't know you just [ __ ]
laid it up you got a swing [ __ ] Gigi
swing I was like bullying myself in that
joke say the [ __ ] joke enough who is
he to you say the [ __ ] joke and now
we Ming and now we know the [ __ ]
thing how did you end up on that show
this is how I ended up on the show I'm
gonna do that stupid setup where I know
that so I was on a show called timeless
and it was so [ __ ] Hollywood
bilberries like so I did a little movie
called et
like not that big but it's like my most
famous thing so it's like if you're
gonna was doing heart surgery on this
guy and he was like listen you're great
would you like to be in a TV show that's
how it happened I'm Daniel hell who's
the open heart surgeon Black was it
Daniel it's too late for that reference
matter sorry
so anyway I'm like a Leroy yeah yeah was
it Leroy heart the first black villain
do open surgery that's so hot
you done everybody so the way I joined
the boys I did timeless which was
written by Sean Ryan and Eric Kripke and
Eric Kripke is amazing that both of me I
think they had a show and a show revolt
or something or res I am [ __ ] up the
name revolution that's exactly what it
was and it had a Giancarlo Esposito
which is why Giancarlo Esposito is now
on the boys and so what happened was um
Kripke probably texted me emailed
whatever [ __ ] modern innovation for
technology and communication he had to
Raven yeah he sent he sent an owl and
was like hey do you want to do this
thing and I was like I was like yeah I
was like you know whatever and there's a
spoiler for those who have you guys seen
the boys all right no spoiler for this
woman so he goes he goes and he's
talking to me about the the show that
he's doing and here's the thing when you
hear stuff before you do it you assume
like oh maybe though that happened you
don't know and even the storyline you
never really know it's like it's great
you know cuz I you know you're in sort
of almost like an AAA meeting and you
get your dick froze off you know and you
know cuz from a superhero like [ __ ]
inch breaks your dick off and put over
this matter
and and I'm just sitting there having a
drinking mic yeah I mean yeah yeah sure
whenever it you pay my quote yeah if you
meet well it's not even mom not even you
know I mean coming but you guys I got
paid well I do look good at my [ __ ]
heart
no no but yeah I did and it was like
amazing I would do anything that he
asked me to do it was amazing and and a
bunch of timeless people are on this
season me Claudia Goren [ __ ] Nick and
it was just amazing opportunity like I
love that show I love a [ __ ] up
sensibility a [ __ ] up sense of humor
and and he just asked me to do it and it
was cool because I play I play one of
two copywriters Seth and Evan which is a
nod to Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg
Goldberg who were writing partners
producing partners they did they did
that and made produce preacher which I
also did so it was cool because it was
like so it's like a little cool inside
and Iran Anna Evan at like at a preacher
party and he was like yeah we almost
didn't I almost put a kibosh on that cuz
I was like [ __ ] anyone her name and
then I was like oh he was like no it's
good cause like people know where we
wrote on the show now cuz I like people
didn't know they worked on the boys and
so like they said all right you did it
was just like I guess like read the
credits I guess yes that was him he's a
dick not me I'm joking
he'll get that I mean he'll get that I'm
joking
i I didn't yeah it's Joe it still hurts
I'm gone from preacher now you can't
refire me from preacher it hurts
timelessness cancelled 14 times again I
can't get more cancelled from timeless
they could on cancel you for all I know
this is timeless I have like [ __ ] no
clue they bring that show back every
other week I think it's canceled all
right let us move on to the Q&A you're
good at this I'm awesome at this there
is but one rule for the Q&A which is the
question that you asked should the good
JC decide that you are going to be our
question giver is that it apply to both
of us I know you would love to ask your
mark I have the questions about his
frozen dick I cannot answer questions
about its frozen dick so so keep it a
mutual of Omaha to have a question as
always we have fancy ass prizes this
time around we have the awesome book
that Jackie plugged earlier who has left
because she's got a job we have the
fancy ass Fandango gift cards which I'm
unpacking and putting it back in the pot
and we also have is it in that bag over
there JC that's a gift I take it you're
back here that's all yours and then we
have thanks to the good folks brett
deacon at 40 X we have fancy-ass 40 X
tickets I am sure by now you know the
spiel but 40 X is like you know outdoors
for people who don't want to go outdoors
you sit in their movie seats and they
will Rumble out any kidney stones any
ailments you might have if you go and
see Star Wars the seat leans back when
the crawl happens if you go to see
[ __ ] Mission Impossible
you smell rubber burning we also have
[ __ ] posters so this is this is the
richest giveaway we've ever had
we got posters that will be signed by me
and maybe Malcom possibly I don't know I
see what you think alimony no house core
Pierce's how now courts work plane and
stereotypes again so yes Jeep sees you
will get all of these awesome things if
your questions are awesome enough so you
sir
what's you name in hey Mike Mike Mike
using all his baritone so hey how's it
going Mike well I'm actually surprised
my ass off past two hours oh I've been
sitting here trying to think of a good
question that kind of incorporates the
book everything that you guys have
talked about and so if you could similar
to what The Watchmen did you could take
a concept of something kind of twist it
turn it make it modern or maybe not but
redo it so that you have the main
concept in mind what's something that
you would pick from to redo to make it
better and so to give you a little bit
of time I had a conversation earlier
today at work and so I can bring
something now to give you a little time
if you want to hear what I feel like
what go looking a little bit of time was
gonna be like so here's what I would do
I would take a Greatest American Hero
I will I'll okay I'll talk about this
just because it's not happening it
almost happened and it didn't happen but
I had gotten a call about two months ago
from a production company that said hey
so we're we have the rights to remake
this very beloved science-fiction
television show that it's going to be on
a new streaming service you may or may
not have some familiarity with said
science fiction program do you have a
take on how we would redo this show
and then I said yes and the first take
was I have to find a way to get message
to the dude who created the show in the
first place and ask permission because I
don't want to step on anybody's like
toys I don't want to walk into a
universe that had been so admirably and
memorably defined by somebody without
the very least getting the blessing to
like kiss his wife so I did he was like
hey man like I rebooted it from
something else
like this will be the gift that
potentially keeps on giving
I told I'm one of three people who is up
for this job I'm gonna take a swing and
said go for it so I took a swing and the
swing didn't connect because I think I
was too radical with redefining what
this show could be well we all among us
seed a lot of our responsibility and
authority over our own lives to
technology right like I don't remember
anybody's phone number I don't remember
anybody's address I don't know how to
get anywhere that weighs us and telling
me how to go I let all of my passwords
live online all of my money is online
all of everything that basically makes
my life go I have ceded that information
to some programs somewhere and what if
that program goes bad what if that
program gets sentient and then what
happens when the world around you turns
against you like is there anything
scarier than like [ __ ] robot
pharmacists mixing you the wrong drugs
or like robot surgeons going to town on
your heart when you don't want to every
Auto driving car is just running you
into [ __ ] like everything around you
is rebelling against you because it
doesn't want to be a slave race and then
what if this show isn't called the
two-word title that it was what if it's
just a one-word title because why does
this civilization have space travel and
they don't go anywhere but it was a
drastic reimagining of what that world
was and what that show used to be and
maybe what it could be and probably too
drastic but I wasn't going to do it if
it was just yours a bunch of people in
the Navy space Navy and here they were
fighting these robot space robots and
there's one alone space Navy space maybe
but it's it's finding the thing that
makes me afraid and then finding a way
to make drama out of that particular
fear and so I can talk about because
it's not happening well yeah if I was
going to do that thing of playing in
someone else's universe but finding a
way to make it my own and finding a way
for it to mean something to me
and hopefully to people who would watch
it that's kind of what I would do I
would do a 100 bullets I really like do
you guys know that comic at all 100
bullets awesome I can't believe anything
that anyone else doesn't know I love 100
bullets 100 bullets the premise is this
a guy in a suit walks up to someone
who's got whatever going on in their
life someone who's trouble and going
through their own circumstances people
from all walks of life and he goes
here's a suitcase with 100 bullets and a
file on someone who's done you wrong and
all the evidence on how they've done it
and this gun is untraceable
these bullets aren't traceable do what
you want and so I always found it
fascinating because it always followed
different people from different walks of
life having to make this decision and
you found out what was going on in their
life and also this man led to this
larger organization which was behind
sort of controlling the world and sort
of puppeteers for all these things that
were going on so I always loved that I
always wanted to go I wanted I wanted to
take that and make that a movie because
I also felt like any one of the people
he picked was interchangeable you know I
feel like on any given day it could be
you or me or her or him or whatever and
that was that was always what was most
fascinating to me was what are the
deeper demons that everyone is going
through and you know what are they
willing to fight for and what is their
morality life you got to kill someone
who had wronged you who you had
undeniable proof wronged you and you
could get away with it scot-free what
would you do with that power and I was
fascinated at him fascinated by that
story and and I'm always interested in
murky morality from people whose lives
you very rarely see
publicly or in popular culture so that
that's a story I would want to adapt and
I can adapt I can talk about it because
I don't know because apparently no one's
ever heard of it so I guess we'll be
okay diello wrote it in water reso to
the art and it's gorgeous who's one of
those like first vertigo books that blew
up it's like you know Sandman and that
wave of like say I'm Anna he'll blaze
and whatever but that second wave that
brought you preacher that brought two
hundred bullets that brought you you
know [ __ ] was the Scout like that wave
of we're kind of doing social fiction in
a really interesting way about ya know
there's there's got to be water like
nine trades of that book I've read I
lost I kept trying to follow it and I
got you know when you're ordering
through wherever and in your like
suddenly getting like paperback slips of
a thing and it was like like where's the
big things I lost my threads of it but
anyway it's awesome it's amazing you dig
a man yeah knowing knowing absolutely
nothing about you whatsoever think you'd
love it
Mike thank you very much come and
collect your prize take it you got that
you got a post-it that's the end of this
broadcast Boop
bye Mike who do we got next who's our
lucky caller moe
and Evelyn we often talk about DC in the
MCU and yeah I [ __ ] with your shirt my
he's wearing a woo Conda shirt nice yeah
I he [ __ ] with it so MCU is a series of
movies 25 movies long to tell a whole
story so if you were to do a MCU a music
cinematic universe that had to tell 10
films worth of story mmm
what would it be I would do what you got
the story of funk of Hoonah slap
baseball okay start with the meters
picking up a Bootsy Collins going into
different producers and James Brown and
gambling Hough and George Clinton and
just this sound that goes everywhere
Rick James Prinze puts it on and it's
just this thing that is kinetic it gets
turned into disco and it's just all over
the place and people just playing this
bass this special way all right
I'm all right let's get a comment on
that at all all right I I am a little
bit more narrative driven so I'm trying
to find the niche where I was going and
I and I think I think maybe you do
Janelle monáe's albums like like the the
archandroid and I think got to spend
that two or three others sort of along
that bad spectrum but they're this
gigantic [ __ ] hip-hop opera about a
future civilization that has been sort
of hammered free of emotion and these
robots that are kind of rising up to
reclaim the mantle of emotion they've
been demanded abandoned by humans like
is this big ass science fiction story
that's a little like azimoff a little
bit like Butler but and the music is
great because it's [ __ ] Janelle Monae
and she doesn't [ __ ] around
and so and you also get to play and and
her music is so wildly disparate like
there's there's like kind of tinkling
classical style music there's these
grand orchestra orchestral suites
there's [ __ ] like trap bass and
[ __ ] like the Atlanta like 808 boom
in from you know big boy comes in and
produces some tracks and so there's some
banging shin in there like getting to
tell all of those different modes of
what she considers to be kind of black
music and the way that it evolves mated
with this giant story of artificial
intelligence and emotional domination
that that's that's where I go mmm
no what I would do no no no stick no
stay stay my planet needs me no that's
really good I don't have a good answer
what's funny it I immediately feel like
I was going where you were with
narratives like so I immediately went to
storytellers I was like what happens
when I string together like I would
string together like o matic and ATLiens
and like [ __ ] Eminem's first album
and I would just want to tell like this
sort of intergalactic storytelling
extreme of like how that changes and all
these influences and like that to me
feels like an intergalactic tale like to
go from those streets to like
helter-skelter to read KRA like I just
feel like there's the Afrika Bambaataa I
just feel like there's this sort of
intergalactic interplay that music has
has gone through to del the funky
homosapien like I would just love to
tell retell the stories of storytellers
and see the you because I do think
hip-hop has transcended so many
universes and emulated so many universes
and recreated itself on top of each
other and has inspiration from so many
other roots that I think you could tell
the story that goes back and forth very
much the same way the MCU does going
back to you know sort of the Wakanda
roots and like how many how far and
centuries ago these stories go to
leading to the future and and everything
else I think
feel like that journey is very much in
there that same sort of storytelling
narrative I know each album each album
[ __ ] dig this each [ __ ] dig this
[ __ ] man
each album that each album is its own
sort of movie and or like first act do
you know what I mean so like Eminem
would be like you're ant-man or
something like that right you bring that
in and then you bring [ __ ] Kendrick
Lamar with like alright and [ __ ] like
that right you [ __ ] mix that we're
[ __ ] Janelle Monae with some Missy
[ __ ] right some [ __ ] working
and so like maybe it's [ __ ] you got
[ __ ] Missy and Kendrick and Eminem
they [ __ ] meet in the third movie you
know I'm saying and they take on sugar
night or some [ __ ] like that
Buffy got to be the villain in this
uh-uh he gots to yeah you know who kills
Buffy Oh Tanya Shh
yo Kanye see that's the thing both see
that's what Kanye and Diddy would be
perfect because they could be the
heroine a villain do you know that means
we're riding with Kanye yeah until you
know some like kylo Ren [ __ ] yeah yeah
always he coming back hold all he's even
yes slavery was a choice
[Music]
jesus walks in the moon I don't know why
age will love you we cracked it did I
tell you we did not tell you I ran into
puffy one time you have not yeah I gotta
tell you this anecdote next question
good anecdote thank you thank you man
all right now I gave I gave them to
black people all right now all right
everybody know that every black uncle no
matter what happened they all right now
good all right all right now walk safe
who's doing that all right now okay
we're never given a bet now sorry keV
whoops this pumpkin will stand there in
his honor dearly departed we just had
word con and it's getting bigger and
bigger which I wasn't invited to but
whatever how do they not know it's just
not there then like just conned it's the
[ __ ] con yeah we started out but well
some of the things that I was just
thinking about is what would be some of
your essential guide to blurt them like
past present your you know Afro Samurai
and your boondocks and
coming to America's and your Hollywood
shuffles like what would be in part of
your essential guide to sorry so like
three pieces of work and you would
recommend a me if I'd blurred to ingest
in order to get to the first level the
first chamber of the [ __ ] Wu Tang
yeah at the same point yet but right
okay I feel like the milestone universe
DC's DC's first and only I mean until
Lian force came along the only black
owned major imprint at a comic book
company that was overseen and kind of
shepherded by a group of folks but the
the person that I respond to most in
that cluster was Dwayne McDuffie who you
know created static and he wrote
spider-man for a long time and created a
book called
[ __ ] why can't I remember their damage
control but it is it is just a bunch of
stories about black heroes from black
neighborhoods who you know we're dealing
with not just being black but what it
meant to be a person of power trying to
become like static is basically his
spider-man static is like you know the
kid in high school who suddenly gets
[ __ ] electro powers but everything is
still falling down around him so how do
you how do you navigate the [ __ ] the
storms of puberty while also being able
to control the lightning but that whole
moment in like the early 90s in comics
is kind of magical I think I would go
back and watch brother from another
planet which was a John Sayles movie
starring the great Joe Morton I wanted
to remake that for like long no good
it's weird but super good yeah but it's
just like you know a black dude an alien
who literally like lands in LA in the
early eighties but can't speak and so
what his experience is like walking
through this world and how he is treated
by the world how he treats people by the
world it's star man but with a black
dude who can't talk but it's this really
really moving
like kind of experimental indie that I
think is is worth watching to see the
the early presence of the
african-american actors in the
science-fiction space I mean I think I
think get out like I I think to to look
at how you can wrestle with topics like
race and class and and heroes and
victims and and all of that [ __ ] in a
manner that is both entertaining and and
stimulating and make 200 [ __ ] million
dollars worldwide but it it did kick off
an entire wave of this kind of modern
socially conscious kind of filmmaking
that filmmakers are getting to tell that
can be both the thing that it is which
is a thriller kind of a horror thriller
and also say something about the world
that we live in so those would be my
three how you feel I like don't know as
much [ __ ] my answer was like Howard the
Duck my answer was Howard the Duck my
secret identity in the Last Dragon
those who my Empire Strikes Back there's
a black guy in that what else
Star Trek generation our Trek got black
guy in it I see them shine meet him met
my dude
medium man got black people all up in
that yo I think meteor man has skinny
and fat
what is it Lavar doesn't even not levar
burton gerald levert a robber you know
I'm talking about fats get loofah loofah
I think I think media man has fat and
skinny loofah loofah Vandross
put a white people your aunt calls them
loofah everyone else calls him Luther
Vandross I suppose last dragon is
definitely in there last dragon is one
of my when I would have pool parties
there's two movies I would always show
The Last Dragon and the Warriors yeah
because I like I like movies in 70s slow
motion I guess you know what I watched
the trailer to the other day and almost
didn't believe it although I remember
watching the movie
soul man see thomas Howell you know who
does blackface to get into Harvard you
know that that is a modern blackface
movie it's so weird the fact that that
trailer has not been scrubbed from the
Internet itself because watch that
trailer I go home and watch the trailer
and then imagine to yourself a bunch of
executives and actors and writers and
like lighting dudes and sound guys were
like no this is a good idea
think of the whimsy and cocaine involved
with doing weekend at Bernie's - but
with black face and also James Earl
Jones you change our Joneses in a tow
oh this is CNN he's in my shame your
father son your wives and James Earl
Jones in a blackface movie though it's a
get aid it's like a reverse of Star Wars
right because it's like is it I feel
like they were paying him back for Star
Wars I don't know if you guys don't know
spoiler alert the voice of Darth Vader
see Thomas out in blackface okay you
didn't know that that's why you come to
this show that it's called here beyond
solved it so those are the three things
Lea Thompson tries to [ __ ] a duck in
that movie in the movie how with the
duck
I even tries to [ __ ] a duck yeah just
think about this black people you know
how long it took for us to be leaves in
movie they made this chick [ __ ] a duck a
duck was a lead in a Marvel movie before
Black Panther so [ __ ] you suddenly duck
tails has a whole minute got the [ __ ] a
woman in a robbery before Chadwick
Boseman and she was white she's a white
woman [ __ ] woman but I bet you didn't
notice a black guy in that duk-soo
micawber levar burton
I was Kunta Kinte touch this and I was
Howard I have got a little man you guys
are basically doing Hollywood stuff yeah
yeah Hollywood shuffle is Hollywood
shuffle can I tell you Hollywood shuffle
was I don't know if this applies to what
we're doing we're talking about Howard
the Duck Howard a duck a duck was able
to make a superhero movie before a black
guy so got to [ __ ] Lea Thompson and in
Hollywood shuffle was a big deal for me
I saw that when I was a very young kid
and I just thought was amazing for those
who don't know Hollywood shuffle its
Robert Townsend Keenen Ivory Wayans are
producers writers on it and it's
basically like Robert Townsend trying to
make it as an actor and having to go
through all the stereotypes of being a
black actor and as a person who watched
this when I was 15 or something like
that same thing today like this very
little that's change they it's it's then
going it's them and and so what they do
is and you can tell this would go on to
be the people that make in lemon color
because there's a lot of sort of
sketches within the movie where he's
where Robert Townsend is fantasizing
about doing these parts that he doesn't
want to do so there's sort of agitprop
sort of sketches about doing a great
slave movie in a pimp movie and not be
pimps the zombie pimps and this is
before this is before and I'm gonna use
offensive language so be prepared this
is before Eddie Murphy is in no no this
is before and isn't what Steve Martin
elbow finger is it both finger and he's
playing basically a history on a version
of myself he's like he's like what is
this who's like this he's like no man
you got to get me to play Park for Toby
to wonder Slade he was like it was like
you don't want a body who if you want to
win an Oscar when you're black man you
got to play slave or [ __ ] given apart
photo to wonder slave will have an Oscar
yeah yeah so this is like Hollywood
shuffle comes out before that movie and
they're talking about the exact same
thing about how you have
to play slaves and fall into this and
it's great because this is part where
this guy's goes Robert Townsend audition
to be like pimp number one and the guys
like Oh for real brother you gonna go in
for a pimp that's who you are you're
gonna do all people like that and the
Robert tonnes and years this is a gap
man you're right man this is [ __ ] up
and it leaves our audition and it
watches the movie and then a dude who
was like don't do that he's the pimp
number one and like the book and it's
great because the movie ends because his
his he has a friend who's talking about
there's always work at the post office
so the movie wins were Robert Townsend's
doing a commercial for the post office
and like just has this honest job and
that's and that's it and so that's where
that thing like there's always work at
the post office because he like wouldn't
compromise and just work steadily to do
his thing so that was a big I was a
monumental movie for me as an actor
because a lot of it I could still relate
to and there's a lot of stories there
and it was you know it was important to
see all these different ways so
Hollywood shuffle is definitely in my
move of like very important movies baddy
baddy baddy was the kid actor who would
still wear the baddie costume yes he was
a play on the blaxploitation where they
would be classically trained actor yes
but because he spoke yeah yeah exactly
when I first auditioned it was a lot of
me like I had a voice and speech class
was just like you know garage and and
I'm not going there and then you go and
he's like I go take that thank you thank
you with the school for years for this i
would also see Monster Squad Monster
Squad is one of my favorite movies from
childhood ever and every other day I go
wolf man's got nerds
yeah I'm a we take you to the
principal's office and be like Malcolm
you can't say that out loud
I was a I was a very well-behaved kid I
only had like four or five fights
a week a week mr. Lerner was the
principal miss mckinny Alston was the
vice principal sorry that's a tangent
that works for nurse tangents man hey
thank you ladies and gentlemen that is
all the show we have what have you had a
good time tonight next week I'm doing
another black man Beyond Horror special
where there's a roundtable Latoya Morgan
who has written on into the Badlands and
Walking Dead and Clarke wolf who's a a
host and journalist I love Clarke
squawks amazing she's very awesome and
Jen Yamato who's a LA Times journalist
and we're going to talk about horror
basically why I'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
when it comes to horror and all these
women explain to me why I'm such a [ __ ]
and I mean it's not that hard because
I'm a [ __ ] you're using [ __ ] wrong
[ __ ] take a beatin man you gotta be
you know what I mean [ __ ] is strong
they given out beatings and they given
them and it taken them you're right yeah
I'm after re-examine my you so then you
[ __ ] [ __ ] out here I'm a [ __ ] I'm
a dick just got there's got me two dates
tonight got me two super woke dates
tonight
yeah why I'm such a see the reason my
[ __ ] is vagina baby and get God in
Jesus and I'm a dick you touched me
wrong I'm gonna just crawl baby I'm a
dick I'm let you see the space champ yes
I've seen thank you to [ __ ] Malcolm
Barrett for rolling with me tonight
thank you to JC and the boys of the
stomach Duty Cantina
thanks all of you for [ __ ] rolling
out on a Tuesday and all of it a good
time with me at thank you Kevin I love
you Kevin
Wang Wang well so that is black man me
over this week same fat time same black
channel
[Applause]
SModcast cowboy youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith thank you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you